[Music]
broke up this is my focus right now but
I have been given platform 2 and I want
to use my voice on that and he probably
just you know gender inequality is
something that is very evident
worldwide really
I think the big miss that happens in
women's sports is to try to replicate
the model that's been done on them
inside I think it is a different product
I think sometimes just doing the the
same exact thing and trying to replicate
that with within the system that has
kept women down for a long time it's
probably not the best way to go about it
I think the big thing that I think about
is more diversity and more
representation of different races
different people giving everyone an
opportunity to succeed and in this
country we haven't been able to achieve
that culture and so because of that we
have a limited pool of people that have
the opportunity
to this level because of the resources
and opportunities they're given as a
child I think sort of it like
incremental change that we've seen is
just not enough I don't think that's
really the model that needs to happen I
would like to see a major paradigm shift
I guess incremental change is better
than none at all
but for the resources and and for the
ability that I feel like FIFA has to
implement that change I think that
they're they're not doing nearly enough
[Music]